wenn sie
Röttgen von dieser chinesischen
Friedensinitiative hören was denken sie
dann ist das ist das eine gute Sache
ich
ärgere mich darüber
dass aus meiner Sicht schon mit dem
Begriff
für die Chinesen ein Erfolg verbunden
ist
wenn wir sagt wir nennen das alle so
es ist die Chinesen haben es geschafft
dass das überall schon der Friedensplan
ist
ich wette also sie haben eben
Voraussagen zitiert aber da bin ich
wirklich es wird nichts es hat nichts
mit Frieden zu tun der höchste
Außenpolitiker also vangi in Nummer zwei
in China ja habe ich das richtig ja
genau
okay das ist ja der wichtigste so und
der besucht
Moskau spricht mit Putin spricht mit auf
und anderen und betont die strategische
Freundschaft und die Bedeutung
das das ist das Gegenteil von Frieden
das ist eine politische Partei name
und sie verfolgen damit eigene
Interessen es ist jetzt ein geschickter
Schachzug sich als
Friedensmacht zu präsentieren zu
porträtieren es wird auch ein Vorschlag
kommen der dient dazu das eigen die
eigene Reputation zu polieren denn in
den Staaten über die wir eben gesprochen
haben die finden unseren Konflikt gar
nicht so wichtig die Europäer wenn bei
denen mal irgendwas ein Krieg ist in
dieser dauernd haben dann muss die ganze
Welt sich damit beschäftigen also er
kommt damit in vielen großen Ländern
Brasilien Südafrika und anderen gut an
auch bei Sahra Wagenknecht die hat
Brasilien mehrfach erwähnt haben und er
und ein bisschen hoffen Sie darauf jetzt
sage ich mal diesen Begriff das ist
nützliche Idioten z.B in Deutschland
gibt die sagen guck mal das ist doch die
Chance also man man man wird auch damit
die Diskussion in den westlichen
Gesellschaften nicht zuletzt in
Deutschland
auch wieder verwirren das wiederum
erzeugt Spaltung zwischen den zu den
zentral- und osteuropäischen und
baltischen Staaten die da sofort alles
erkennen und völlig klarsichtig sind
also das ist ein ein diplomatischer
Q den China da jetzt landen wird nach
meiner Einschätzung aber wie gesagt
schon mit dem Begriff und der
Platzierung und Verwendung des Begriffs
ist ihnen ein gewisser Erfolg gelungen
das ist eben dieses déjà vu was zitiert
haben was ich da habe also ich war ja
wie viel in meiner Generation sehr aktiv
in der Friedensbewegung in den 1980er
Jahren und die wurde ja auch befeuert
dadurch dass von der Sowjetunion damals
immer so genannte
Friedensinitiativen kamen Abzug von paar
Panzern aus der DDR oder Sachen die eine
weiter Ferne waren Verschrottung der
Atomwaffen die aber alle gut klingen
noch viele im Westen sagten naja es
hinter die Amerikaner die die Aufrüstung
wollen und die so weg ich möchte Frieden
und genau das ist das was chitting Ping
jetzt anstrebt mit der großen
friedensrede wir halten möchte was ist
die sozusagen können Sie es mal
deklinieren was was ist das was da jetzt
passieren könnte was ist die Theorie gut
der fährt dahin der redet mit Putin das
ist ein abgekartetes Spiel oder was
würden Sie sagen naja was der Inhalt
sein wird kann man ja daraus schließen
also jetzt am diese Woche hat ja
chingang der neue chinesische
Außenminister ein anderes Papier
vorgelegt nämlich eine sogenannte
globale
Sicherheitsinitiative und wenn man das
was da drin steht runter bricht auf die
Ukraine bedeuten dass
Waffenruhe Verhandlungen die Sicherheit
Besorgnisse von allen heiß ernst nehmen
das heißt ja praktisch halt Russlands
Sicherheit Interesse dass die Ukraine
nicht in die NATO kommt oder keine keine
in Beziehungen zum wessen hat dann nicht
Einmischung das heißt übersetzt keine
Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine und
noch ein Schritt weiter keine Sanktionen
weil das ist ja auch ein wichtiger
Bestandteil der Rhetorik der
chinesischen Führung zu sagen solche
Sanktionen was die USA machen das ist ja
an sich schon ein Verbrechen und das
wird das sein aber das wird von seiner
Rede noch viel viel schöner formuliert
werden und das wird bei uns Einfluss auf
die Politik haben auf die
Friedensbewegung aber wie sie schon
richtig sagten herausfinden natürlich
doch viel mehr in den Ländern des
sogenannten globalen Süden sieht aber
auch in Rio de Janeiro gelebt hat man
schon immer die Gringos die Amerikaner
für alles Böse auf der Welt
verantwortlich gemacht und da werden
jetzt alles sagen ja jetzt gibt's auch
einen guten Friedensvorschlag von China
und das Ziel ist das sind relativ zu
verändern von dem
relativ russland hat die Ukraine
überfallen zum chinesischen Friedensplan
und die Generale Liste ist alles das
genau ist und die Prämisse ist da ist
die Wirklichkeit ist es gibt ein Land
das greift ein anderes an überfällt das
andere und die diese Prämisse wird
getauscht da ist eben Krieg zwei führen
Krieg und darum müssen
ja total
interessante Krieg endet dann wenn einer
aufhört so ist es genau so ist es so das
ist das ist die grundlegende Veränderung
über die gar nicht viel gesprochen wird
sondern da ist Krieg genauso ist beide
führen Krieg und jetzt müssen mal beide
vernünftig werden beide müssen aufhören
zu kämpfen beide müssen dann
Verhandlungen führen und das ist die
Veränderung die beigeführt wird der
Unterschied ist wenn wenn Russland
aufhörte zu schießen dann wäre
tatsächlich der Krieg zu Ende aber wenn
wir auch dass man nicht fest vorschlägt
die Ukraine aufhört sich zu verteidigen
das heißt folgendes Szenario die treffen
sich die reden miteinander dann schlägt
man einen Friedensplan vor was auch
immer das dann sein wird aber der so
formuliert ist dass die Ukraine und der
Westen das nicht akzeptieren können und
dann hat man die Erzählung schaut euch
das mal an wie wollen noch Frieden aber
die Amerikaner der Westen die wollen das
alle nicht die wollen eigentlich dass
dieser Krieg weitergeht und damit trägt
man sozusagen diese Erzählung in diese
ohnehin schon gespaltene auch deutsche
Gesellschaft rein die man damit weiter
auseinander bringt ist das eine These
die ich zustimmen würden ja ich halte
das für ein ganz gefährlichen Moment wo
wir jetzt stehen tatsächlich da wir auch
merken dass in vielen anderen Ländern in
der Türkei in Brasilien in Indien es
gibt eine interessante Umfrage des
European Counter und relations
festgestellt haben dass viele Menschen
in der Türkei oder in Indien halt eben
Russland als Partner sehen und auch als
Partner erhalten wollen und deshalb
durch genau dieser gefährlichen und
vollkommen falschen These dass dort
irgendwie zwei Streithähne
miteinander im Clinch sein und dass die
jetzt mal aufhören mögen und im Grunde
genommen die ganze
die Tatsache des Überfalls einfach unter
den Teppich gekehrt wird so und bei uns
glaube ich ist jetzt könnte sich das
ebenso verbreiten und tatsächlich völlig
in Vergessenheit geraten dass dieser
Krieg von heute auf morgen beendet
werden könnte wenn Russland aufhört
voranzugehen wenn Russland aufhört zu
schießen die Ukraine selbst könnte in so
einem Friedensplan wenn man sich jetzt
einigte darauf dass die Grenzen so wie
sie jetzt sind eingefroren werden ein
einfach nur ein zerstückeltes nicht
lebensfähiges Land sein dass nur noch
sehr sehr wenig zu umso mehr hat
überhaupt
und damit letztendlich die nächste
Etappe des putinischen Planes das
russische Territorium zu erweitern und
die Ukraine letztendlich als einen Torso
stehen zu lassen damit erfüllt werden
das ist die große Gefahr abgesehen davon
frau Klein
Anthony blinken hat dieser Tage einen
Interview gegeben da geht es am kalt den
Rücken runter wenn man das so hört hat
nicht gesagt dass es so ist aber hat
gesagt wir glauben dass es passieren
könnte nämlich dass die Chinesen mit
Waffenlieferungen für Russland aktiv in
diesem Krieg Eingreifen wir hören einmal
ganz kurz rein was wichtig ist auf jedes
einzelne Wort zu achten bitte schön
also das wäre wirklich ein Bruch der
bisherigen Linie Pekings muss man sagen
die ja versuchen sich ebenso eine
Position zu erarbeiten wo man sagen
könnte wir sind diejenigen die beide
zusammenbringen das wäre eine einseitige
einseitiges Eingreifen zugunsten
Russlands was wir schon sehen ist dass
zunehmend
chinesische Firmen denn westlichen
export-technologie Stopp umgehen also
Chips Halbleiter und so weiter liefern
die für Russlands Rüstungsindustrie ja
wichtig sind weil das die Güter sind die
fehlen als Komponenten um eigentlich
tatsächlich die Rüstungsindustrie im
großen Mengen wieder voranzutreiben
gerade moderne Waffen in Russland das
ist der erste Punkt der da ist und das
andere ist natürlich dass man sicherlich
über solche Dinge wie Munition
beispielsweise über Drittländer dann
nachdenken könnte also ich sehe im
Moment noch nicht das wirkliche große
Waffensysteme aus China direkt geliefert
werden das würde dann wirklich den
Konflikt
multi-krise und multikonflikte Russland
Ukraine
dritten Weltkrieg bitte das wird ja so
oft beschworen die haben das klingt dann
auch schon so dass man sagt na gut da
geht jemand sozusagen komplett in die
Apokalypse aber das wäre tatsächlich
eine völlige Veränderung das wäre
komplett das würde dann wirklich so
diesen bipolaren Konflikt USA China noch
mal viel stärker überholen und in diesen
Konflikt hier reinbringen deswegen für
Kinder werden dann auch eine klare
Positionierung in diesem Konflikt gegen
Europa da ich weiß nicht ob das im
chinesischen Interesse im Moment ist
sehe ich eigentlich nicht von dem her
habe ich dafür noch nicht genau das ist
entscheidende Punkt das ist doch Adrian
Geiges Fragen der dieses chinesisches
System macht ziemlich gut kennt ich
meine
es gibt von von Leuten die harari zum
Beispiel ja der der weiß immer wieder
darauf hin und sagt kluge startenführer
führen keine Kriege und alle
prosperierenden Länder haben sehr lange
keine Kriege geführt Länder die keine
Kriege führen sind die die auf der Welt
aber erfolgreichsten sind weil Frieden
Länder einfach wachsen lässt und blühen
und gedeihen lässt
das war ja immer auch die chinesische
Linie aber seit sie hat man doch das
Gefühl da geht es jetzt schon auch um
mehr also wenn man sich anschaut wie der
nur als Beispiel mit seinen
digitalkonzernen z.B umgeht Jack ma
Alibaba ist nur ein Beispiel also wie
man die beschnitten hat wo man reingeht
und sagt okay Wirtschaft ist wichtig
Wohlstand ist wichtig dieses Versprechen
wir machen euch alle wohl haben da als
als Partei alles wichtig aber jetzt
geht's immer mehr auch um Ideologie am
Ende geht es auch um Kommunismus um
unsere Art von Demokratie wie Sie es
nennen und das ist uns jetzt schon
wichtig also ein Kampf der Systeme und
dann verbünden sich diese beiden auch am
Vorabend des Krieges ist ja auch
passiert vor einem Jahr passiert hier
und Putin die sich im picking anlässlich
der Olympischen Spiele treffen was die
beiden da besprochen haben weiß man bis
heute nicht was ich auf jeden Fall
gemerkt habe ist es gab von chinesischer
Seite als der kriegt dann wirklich
begann nie eine ernsthafte Note an den
ernsthaften Widerspruch gegen Weltkrieg
das heißt halten Sie es für möglich dass
die Chinesen da wirklich reingehen ja
man muss das in das große Bild einordnen
also was schitting macht also wie Sie
richtig sagen er geht ja ab von dem was
in China vorher war nur auf die
Wirtschaft Geld verdienen Geschäfte
machen jetzt geht's wieder um Ideologie
so und es geht auch nicht mehr um
Zurückhaltung weltweit was er vorher der
Fall war sondern es geht jetzt darum
China bis zum Jahr 2009 40 Tag der
Volksschule China zum führenden Land der
Erde zu machen und da ordnet sich auch
diese große sogenannte
Friedensinitiative ein das ist einfach
nur noch Initiative sagen das finde ich
gut das richtige framing für diese
Sendung jetzt hier ja da ordnet sich
diese Initiative ein denn es geht dann
noch einen Schritt weiter es geht ja
nicht nur darum irgendwie den Westen
verantwortlich zu machen sondern es geht
auch darum den Westen zu spalten Europa
auf der einen Seite und die USA auf der
anderen Seite also es ist sehr
interessant zu lesen was in diesen Tagen
in den chinesischen Zeitungen steht aber
auch was wangi der oberste
Außenpolitiker bei der
Sicherheitskonferenz in München sagte
und bei anderen öffentlichen Auftritten
im letzten Tagen sagte da sagte
eigentlich hat die Europäer quasi
ermuntert ihr müsst euch doch endlich
mal auf eure eigenen Interessen besinnen
und nicht ständig von diesen Amerikanern
vorantreiben lassen und auch die Ukraine
wird nämlich nicht angegriffen also
nicht von China die sagen wir haben ja
auch zur Ukraine gute Beziehung haben
sie auch tatsächlich gehört Wirtschaft
und die sagen die Ukraine die wird von
von den USA quasi schlecht beeinflusst
die diesen da Öl ins Feuer und die
Amerikaner sind schuld an diesem Krieg
und wir haben ja vorhin darüber
gesprochen wenn Sie das so sagen dieser
Text kommt mir so bekannt vor habe ich
in dieser Woche schon mal gehört ja
weiter und wir sprechen ja vorhin über
die Rolle die Fotos in dieser Propaganda
haben und zwar dieses Foto von Scholz
auf dem Panzer es gibt ein anderes Foto
dass in diesen Tagen in den chinesischen
Zeitungen ist das sind Fotos halt
zufällig aufgenommen da unterschreibt
beiden irgendwas und
silence gesteht so ein bisschen
bedröppelt dabei das ist sicherlich
zufällig deshalb gerade dahin gegangen
oder stand da gerade und das wird in
China so interpretiert da sieht man es
doch die USA die geben das Kommando und
die Ukraine selbst die haben ja gar
nichts zu sagen das sind ja quasi
Marionetten der Amerikaner aber
alles das was sie beide gesagt haben
spricht dagegen was China Waffen liefert
an Russland es würde damit diese gesamte
Politik der gesamte Ansatz
zusammenbrechen
denn der beruht darauf wir sind die
Friedensmacht wir sagen die beiden
führenkrieg wir müssen vernünftig sein
wir sind eben gerade nicht die
Amerikaner die machen das ja und darum
also ich würde mich ich muss sagen ich
würde mich ich halte es für praktisch
ausgeschlossen und es wäre ein absoluter
kurswandel der chinesischen Außenpolitik
die Chinesen wollen den Süden gewinnen
gegen die USA sie wollen den West
sozusagen sie wollen den wir sind der
Westen und sie wollen den Rest gewinnen
und das machen sie jetzt so geschickt
aber wenn sie Waffen liefertigen und
dann auch militärisch Partei würden
würde dieser Ansatz völlig kontaktiert
darum glaube ich ist eigentlich nicht
und haben nicht die chinesenheit an sie
alle in der Runde die große Sorge
Sanktionen also wenn man sieht wozu der
Westen dann doch auch in der Lage ist
also die die Sanktionen Richtung
Russland
das es beginnt richtig zu wirken ist
schlecht genau irgendwann mal sagte
jemand ich war die notenbankchefin also
kurzfristig machen uns diese Sanktion
nichts und wenn die Frage kommt wirken
die über die mal sagen nein kurzfristig
nein aber langfristig definitiv
kurzfristig zu null Prozent und
langfristig zu 100 %. ist das nicht die
große Sorge der Chinesen das ist die
große Sorge der Chinesen aber es ist
auch die Sorge die die Russen aktuell
haben denn natürlich sind die Sanktionen
die bisher in Kraft sind die hat sie die
die Rosen waren zunächst schockiert dann
haben sie sich angepasst daran
und jetzt sind wir in einer Situation wo
einiges was langfristig angelegt wird
wirkt der russische Staatshaushalt
tatsächlich
massiv ins Minus gegangen ist und
gleichzeitig Öl und gaseinnahmen die sie
vorher hatten im vergangenen Jahr
ausbleiben und man sieht aber doch wie
sie sich immer wieder anpassen und da
kommen die Chinesen ins Spiel weil und
übrigens auch die Türkei weil über die
Türkei über China kommen Güter ins Land
die wir längst auf der Sanktionsliste
haben und deshalb sind Sanktionen auch
keine Sache die man einmal machen kann
sondern muss ständig sehen wie versuchen
die Russen verändern
versuchen sie wieder Güter ins Land zu
bekommen mit denen sie dann auch wieder
Hightech-Waffen herstellen können und
wie müssen wir das verhindern und da
glaube ich liegt dann auch in Peking die
Befürchtung dass man da halt eben
tatsächlich über sekundär ist ja
Sanktionen mit inhaft genommen werden
könnte und das bestimmte Güter dann
nicht mehr geliefert werden so wie heute
jetzt hier schon Hightech Chips nicht
mehr geliefert werden aber da hat eben
cheating Ping eine langfristige
Strategie dagegen zum einen dass er ja
seine Leute verdonnert hat Autarkie zu
erreichen also gerade bei Halbleitern
Computerchips und so weiter made in
China 2025 solche Kampagnen also er
möchte ja genau dem vorbeugen indem er
China autark macht das ist das eine und
das andere ist dass er eine weltweite
auch
wirtschaftsfreund sage ich mal bilden
will die unabhängig von den Amerikanern
und unabhängig vom US-Dollar ist also er
versucht das ja voranzutreiben und da
hilft ihm sogar der Ukraine kriegt
vielleicht bisschen weil Russland jetzt
nicht mehr mit dem Dollar handeln kann
ja lass uns doch unsere jünger
ist ja noch nicht da er braucht dafür
Zeit ich würde sagen sie kann in der
jetzigen Lage wo er große
auch unter Druck ist kovic Strategie
völlig gescheitert
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit in eine Häuser
immobilienproblem Immobilienblase und so
weiter er kann keine globale
Wirtschaftskrise gebrauchen er hat nur
weil sie es auch eben gesagt haben er
hat auf dem G20-Gipfel
Putin öffentlich belehrt dies ist keine
Zeit für Kriege und den Satz und das ist
auch Dich das erste Stimme sowieso
obwohl der Krieg stattfindet aber das
ist die chinesische Interessenlage wir
werden es sehen aber es würde alles
all dem widersprechen was bislang
chinesischen Politik ist und darum wenn
wir jetzt schon im spekulieren sind
vielleicht war es auch in amerikanischer
versuch also weiß es nicht darauf
hinzuweisen sozusagen kommunikativ zu
konterkarieren die sich Chinesen sind in
Wahrheit Partei denn das war ja auch in
der Wartung und nach der Ankündigung
dieses Spiel dieser Initiative gemacht
worden und ich glaube dass die
Amerikaner das in Washington genauso
analysiert wird was sind eigentlich die
Wirkungen dieser Initiative da werden
die ungefähr so ähnlichen schlussform
vielleicht gekommen sein und dass sie
dem nur zuschauen und sagen dass lassen
wir jetzt mal alles geschehen ist ja
auch unwahrscheinlich aber das ist
natürlich auch spekulativ